[Music]
first on CBS this morning the Library of
Congress is revealing its newest
national ambassador for young people's
literature that's a big title the
two-year position aims to raise the
nation's appreciation of youth
literature as it relates to literacy
education and the development and
betterment of lives so we are very
excited to announce our nation's newest
national ambassador for young people's
literature drum roll please it's he's a
best-selling and award-winning author
and poet his work includes patina his
brave is you my personal favorite long
way down he writes for young adult
audiences Reynolds was named at the
position by the Library of Congress
that's Carla Hayden and they both join
us now at the table Carla may I say good
excellent excellent thank you and Jason
this is what I want to know from you
what does this position mean to you and
what do you intend to do with it I mean
I mean it means an awful awful lot but
it's and also a tremendous
responsibility I think for me to be the
ambassador of anything is to proliferate
the ideas of said thing that you were
championing
but I also think because I'm dealing
with young people and young people's
literature I'm choosing to focus more so
on rural and small-town America because
I can't claim to love children if I only
love some of them and I find that
sometimes we overlook the kids in Iowa
the kids in Nebraska and small-town
Alabama in upstate New York right yeah
and so my job is to make sure that I go
there interact with them allow us to
have human moments because I believe
that if narrative is currency we can't
just focus on external narrative he has
to focus on internal narrative as well I
know Jason you said here is someone who
didn't even read a whole book until you
were 17 of course and now you you're an
ambassador for reading absolutely and I
think I would have read books earlier
had I had more of this interaction not
just about the books that were being
written at the time but if anybody would
have come to see me yeah let me know
that they are the ones behind these
words and I could buy into them that I
could buy into the war Carla why did you
pick you just heard it what better
ambassador someone who didn't have the
books that he needed to get him excited
about reading who can interact with
anytime he's a rock star in young adult
literature young people of all ages and
types and sizes and colors stand in line
for two hours I've seen it to interact
with him and so an ambassador the
Library of Congress the largest library
in the world we're promoting literacy
and reading to have Jason go and be that
ambassadors just wonderful so the
department education which tracks
reading scores they came out with some
numbers recently weren't very good then
they were going in the wrong direction
for eighth graders I think was fourth
and eighth graders
yeah what do you make of that Jason
makes a good point that I think yeah I
think it's tricky one I'm not one to
negate necessarily need to negate the
statistics but what I will say is that
statistics don't tell whole truth you're
seeing some encouraging things you're
saying I'm on the ground and I'm on the
ground every day right all over this
country and what I'm seeing is tons of
people becoming more tons of young
people getting more and more excited now
the translation of that excitement to
the test scores is an interesting thing
but are there more young people reading
is what I'm saying they're not reading
books yet they're on social media or
something they think you're an
interesting personality then they find
out you're an author yeah I think I
think it's there there's that element so
and there's also look there's currency
and coup as much as there's currency
yeah yeah people just want to do
whatever the cool thing is and right now
there are a lot of kids who really
believe depending upon the book that
reading is cool we saw it happen with
Harry Potter we start happening with
tons of but Angie stones they hate you
give all right you see that happen right
now and so I believe that it's all about
making sure that we're giving them the
thing that they want and need and then
showing up for them to make it real for
you would it reading do from these did a
few things number one it showed me who I
was it helped me to navigate the world
that I lived in and helped me to
navigate my internal space and who I was
as a person but more than all those
things it gave me soft skills that I
used to manage my life in order to read
anything we have to have discipline
patience concentration listening skills
listen to yourself to then synthesize
that information now those are the same
skills that you will need to manage a
job a relationship and to do well in
school it's bigger than just narrative
it's also the the external macro stuff
Carla what do we do to get more kids
reading we have other than put Jason out
there we have to provide the books that
they might want to read and not be
judgmental and I brought a copy of the
book and from 1946 it was late April
right April when I was a little girl
this in Jamaica Queens little Branch
Library this was the only book that had
someone that looked like being yeah and
I love to read books should be windows
on the world but they should be mirrors
yeah he said we know judgment why is
that so important well sometimes we want
young people to read the great novels
and things and not a graphic novel if
you see them and you poopoo it and
things like that no reading you have
it's like a muscle anything it's like a
muscle you you you get practice so
you're reading comic books you're
reading out and we have the world's
largest collection of comic books so
Jason and the Library of Congress is
that library not a lending library there
yeah but so that's what we're we're
really hoping that Jason can Jason where
did you make your first connection to
reading what was it you remember it's a
reading yeah absolutely was that lit you
up seventeen and a half years old
Richard Wright's black boy yeah and what
lit me up about it was that it wasn't a
50 page exposition page two we were
right in the midst of the drama yeah
page two right I think it is I think
it's interesting that we expect young
people to want to read fifty pages of
exposition when they when they live in
two minute worlds where things are
happening rapidly yeah so my job as a
writer is to write something that has a
hook in the beginning by the way adults
also don't like to read 50 page expose
right it was the hook and once I got to
the hook and I got to a book then it
became the obsession with completion
yeah and then my boss started to roll
yeah and it's still rolling Carl hey
Carla Hayden and Jason Reynolds thank
you both very much
look out there in Nebraska small-town
Alabama
you